สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนัก
[เพลง]
เรียนโอเคกลับมาพบกับครูฟ้าแล้วก็ครู
เรียมนะคะในชั่วโมง beginner  4 นะคะ B4
แล้วเนาะอืใช่แล้วค่ะวันนี้มาเจอกันวัน
อะไรเอ่ยวันนี้มาเจอกันวันพุธค่ะวันพุธ
วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 7 ค่ะอื
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กันยายน
กัยายนโอเคพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
[เพลง]
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะอืตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา
1455 น 14 นต้องเขียนเป็น 14
14 จุ 55 นอืใช่แล้วค่ะแรู้สึกแบบง่วง
มากเลยอ่ะครูฟาครูเรียมไหวมั้ยคะเมื่อกี้
ครูฟ้าเล่านิทานให้ครูเรียมฟังในวีดีโอ
ที่แล้วไงคุเรียมก็เลยง่วงใช่คิดว่าใกล้
จะหลับละตายแล้วถ้าครูฟ้าเล่านิทานใน
วีดีโอนี้อีกให้ครูเรียมฟังนะคะครูเรียม
ต้องหลับแน่ๆเลยใช่ค่ะเรียมก็เลยตอนแรก
เล็มคิดว่าจะเล่าเล่า่านิทานแต่ก็แบบไม่
โอเคอ่ะมันง่วงง่วงมากเพราอากินข้าวกิน
ข้าวเยอะมากแล้วก็
อง่วงถ้าอย่างงั้นไม่เล่านิทานแล้วเราจะ
ทำอะไรคะคู่เรียมเราก็จะเล่นเกมค่ะโหครู
ป้าชอบเล่น
เกมชอบเล่นเกมอืเรียมเพึ่งไปค้นหามาเมื่อ
กี้ใน iPad แล้วก็โหลดเกมไว้ใน iPad นะคะ
เห็นเกมนี้น่าเล่นมากมันคือเกมอะไรอ่ะครู
เรียมพเค้าบอกว่าเป็นเกมแบบอะไรนะเดี๋ยว
อ่านชื่อก่อนชื่อเกมชื่อเกม slap  King
slap  King
slap  slap  King ถ้าเกิดภาษาไทยเขาจะ
บอกว่ายังไงตราชาราชาของการตบ slap  King
เหรอใช่คือตบเก่งมากใช่ไหมเราบอกว่าตบ
อย่างงี้เหรอคะแล้วมันเล่นยังไงอ่ะครู
เรียมเดี๋ยวเราไปดูกันว่ามันเล่นยังไงม
แชร์ให้ดูได้ค่ะเมก็ไม่เคยเล่นนะแต่ใจมาก
แค่รู้สึกว่าง่วงอืมก็เลยสักหน่อยสัก
หน่อย
สปิพตื่นเต้นมาก
โอเคแต่ว่าก็ไม่มีใครเคยเล่นเลยนะครูฟ้า
ก็ไม่เคยเล่นเรียมก็ไม่ไม่เคยใช่เนี่ย
เปิดขึ้นมาก็เจอแบบนี้อันนี้คือครูฟ้ากับ
ครูเรียมไม่เคยเล่นเกมนี้มาก่อนเลยนะคะ
ไม่แบบว่าไม่เคยเล่นมาก่อนใช่เดี๋ยวเราดู
รอบๆชอบกันดีกว่าว่าเค้ามีอะไรบ้างได้ค่ะ
พเดมเดมเห็นแบบผู้ชายคนเนี้ยที่แบบมีผ้า
เค้าเรียกว่าอะไรนะผ้าโพกหัวสีเขียวผ้า
พพกหัวแบบว่าเออแล้วก็เ้ากำลังทำมือแบบ
เหมือนแบบพร้อมแล้วพร้อมผมพร้อมที่จะ
ตกใช่แล้วก็แปลว่าในเกมเนี่ยจะต้องมีการ
แคแข่งกันใช่มยครูคิดว่าเป็นคเป็นการแข่ง
นะคะเพราะว่ามันจะต้อง
ได้ถ้วยมมีอืไม่แน่ใจนะแต่มันมีคำว่าแบบ
เลเวล 1
เออน่าจะเป็นการแข่งกันค่ะครูเลียมน่าจะ
เป็นการแข่งกันแข่งกันก็จะมีคนแข่งอยู่ 2
คนใช่มยอันนี้คนที่ 1 กับคนที่ 2 ใช่ๆอื
ก็แข่งตบหน้ากันเนี่ยนะแข่งตบ
นะคะเบอกให้กดเพื่อที่จะตบใช่มยดูแซบเรม
เรียมอยากให้แบบครูป้าเล่นกับเรียมมากเลย
อ่ะมันเล่นออนไลน์ได้มอ่ะมันเล่นออนไลน์
ไม่ได้ครูเรียมอุ๊ยมันมีคนเชียร์อยู่ข้าง
ล่างด้วยนะใช่ๆๆโอหมีคนเชียร์ด้วยนะคะมี
คนให้กำลังใจนะคะเราบอกว่าให้กำลังใจสู้ๆ
สู้ๆให้กำลังใจเต็ม
เลยโอเคพร้อมแล้วค่ะเดี๋ยวเรียมจะตกแล้ว
พร้อมครูเรียมกดที่หน้าจอ iPad ใช่มั้ยคะ
เพื่อที่จะตกใช่เาบอกว่าให้กด Tab  to
slap ก็คือแบบกดเพื่อตบอ่ะมาเป็นจะลองตบ
อ๋อมันต้องดูตรงนี้ด้วยนะครูฟ้าตรงไหนตรง
อันนี้ๆๆๆๆเรียมเห็นตรงเนี้อตรงนี้มัน
อ๋อเนี่ยๆ่ะตรงเนี้ยมันเหมือนเป็นที่วัดม
มันก็จะมีสีแดงสีส้มสีเหลืองสีเขียวเขียว
อ่อนเขียวเข้มสีอะไรที่มันแรงที่สุดอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าเป็นสีอะไรแรงคือตบแรงแรอื
ครูฟ้าว่าครูเรียมจะต้องกดให้ได้สีเขียว
เข้มค่ะสีเขียวเข้มตรงนี้เนี่ยสีเขียว
เข้มที่ครูฟ้าวงไว้เนาะอ๋อโอเคโอเคพร้อม
แล้วเดี๋ยวเรืมลองดูอ่าอึ้ยอ้ยโดนไป
เดี๋ยว
ๆ
ออมีตีลังกาแบบม้วนตัวตกเมื่อกี้เมื่อกี้
ผู้ชายคน
นี้ตีลังกาเหรอคะตีลังกาตีลังกาโอ้โหกับ
หลังตีลังกาด้วยนะแบบตีลังกาแล้วก็ตบอื
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าเมื่อกี้นี้เรียมก็กดได้
แถวๆนี้นะมคิดว่าเรียมกดได้แบบสีเขียว
อ่อนๆนะสีเขียวอ่อนใช่มูมได้สีเขียวอ่อน
ถ้าได้สีเขียวเข้มจะเป็นยังไงเดี๋ยวิมจะ
ลองดูอ่ะพร้อมค่ะทุกคนพร้อม
ค่ะ 1  2
ออยโหตบแรงมากแรงมากตบแรงมากค่ะโหเค้าก็
ตบแรงเหมือนกันครูฟ้าว่าตัวเลขตรงเนี้ย
ครูเหลี่ยมอืมันจะเป็นแบบว่าออของเรายัง
ใช่มอืมคือพลังหรือเปล่าไม่รู้แต่ของเรา
48 เนี่ยเรามากกว่าใช่มั้ยของคนนี้เนี่ย
31 อืแปลลว่าเราจะชนะนะคะเรามีมากกว่า
ใช่ๆมากกว่า 31 อืโอ้โหแบบเค้าขู่มาด้วย
อ่ะเค้าแบบทำท่าขู่อ่ะครูฟ้าอุ๊ยผู้ชาย
ที่ใส่หมวกอ่ะผู้ชายที่ใส่หมวกหรอเคทำท่า
นี้หรอเ็มชอบแว่นเ้ามากเรมตบตบหน้าแว่น
เค้าก็ยังอยู่อ๋อนี่นะคะแว่นเใส่แว่นนะสี
ส้มโอเคครูฟ้าอยากให้เรียมกดไปโดนสีอะไร
ดีครูเรียมลองสีเหลืองดูมสีเหลืองเหรอได้
ๆๆอ่ะลองแล้ว
นะอ๋ออันนี้ตบเบาๆโอโอตบคืนแรง
มากผู้ชายคนนี้กระโดดตบค่ะค่ะนักเรียน
เมื่อกี้คือกระโดดตบนะคะนักเรียนย้อนไปดู
กระโดดแล้วก็ตบเหมือนวอลเลย์บอลน่ะกระด
ลองลองสังเกตดูนะแบบเวลาโดนตบแล้วก็จะเซ
อือคนที่โดนตบก็จะเซอ่ะครูฟ้าเอาสีอะไรดิ
เลยเค้าเหลืออีก 3 นนะเเหลืออีก 3 เหรอ
อีกฝั่งนึงอ่ะเราเอาสีแดงมั้ยเบาๆสีแดง
อลองสีแดงอเราแบบสีแดงสงสารโอ้สงสารสีแดง
มยโอโนอน
เลยตบครั้งสุดท้ายเนี่ยผู้ชายคนนั้นนอน
เลยนะคะล้มเราบอกว่าล้มแล้วก็นอนใช่มย
หรือว่าน็อคหรือว่าสลบนะพูดได้อือ้าวมี
คู่ต่อสู้ใหม่แล้วเอ้าเปลี่ยนคนแล้วเหรอ
คะครูเรียมเปลี่ยนคนค่ะตอนนี้แบบเป็นคน
ใส่เสื้อแบบแจ็คเก็ตแล้วก็หัวร้านเน่ะโอ้
มีขาด้วยแหละออมีเคราด้วยเคราสีน้ำตาลใช่
มั้ยอุยแต่ว่าพลังเ้าเยอะมากเลยนะครูฟ้า
เห็นมั้ยอุ๊ยเ้ามีของเรามี
100 ส่วนของเขาคมี 125 นะคะสีเขียวนี้
เราบอกว่าเป็นพลังชีวิตเนาะอืพลังพลัง
ชีวิตนะคะพลังชีวิตใชู่ฟ้าเอาเท่าไหร่ดี
เอาสีเขียวก่อนค่ะสีเขียวนะอสีเขียวเข้ม
ด้วยสีเขียวเข้มอุยได้เขียวอ่อนได้เขียว
อ่อนอ๋อดีใจผู้ชายคนนี้หมุนตัวตบนะคะ
โอหตบแรงมากแรงหมุนตัวก็คือหมุนหมุนเนาะ
หมุนอแบบหมุนแล้วก็ตบโหไม่ธรรมดานะเนี่ย
โอเคแบบรู้สึกแบบกองเชียร์ข้างล่างเนี่ย
จะสนุกกันใหญ่มากสนุกๆ
อ้าตบเลยตบเลยโอเคมจะเอาให้สีเขียวตรง
กลางต้องลองสีเขียวดูนะคอเซ
เซ
อ๋อจมูกแดงแล้วกูเรียมไม่ได้แล้วนะเพราะ
ว่าพลังชีวิตของเราเหลือ 36 แล้วค่ะอุ๊ย
พลังชอผู้ชายคนนี้เหลือ 58 ครูเรียมอุย
ผู้ชายคนนี้มากคุเรียมดูหน้าเเหรอเออหน้า
แดงเอจมูกแดงละ
จมูกแดงแก้มแดงแล้วนะคะแก้มแดงแล้วหรือ
เอายังไงดีอ่ะต้องสีเขียวเท่านั้นใช่ไหมม
ครูปลาเขียวเข้มค่ะครียมต้องสีเขียว
เข้มอู้หแรงนะแรงอุยเรียมจะตายมย
เนี่ยทีเดียว
โอ้โหอันนี้เนี่ยเราแพ้ค่ะนักเรียนแพ้แพ
ออเราแพ้ดูเ้าเต้นอ่ะเค้าเต้นด้วยหรอเค้า
เต้นน่ะเเต้นข้างหลังอันนี้อะไรเนี่ย
รางวัล 50 เอ้าๆมีปลาฉลามด้วยนะคะฉลามมา
คิดว่ามันเป็นโฆษณาใช่มยครูปาเอออันนี้
โฆษณาโฆษณาไม่เกี่ยวกันเพราะว่ามันเป็น
เกมฟรีใช่ค่ะเกเกเราก็ต้องลองโฆษณาใช่เกม
ฟรีมันจะมีโฆษณานะคะนักเรียนใช่อันนี้ก็
คือเป็นเกมๆอื่นที่เขาเอามาให้เราดูถ้า
อยากเล่นเราก็จะกดโหลดเกมนี้เข้ามาใน
เครื่อง
อืน่าจะใช่โอโอถ้าเกิดไม่อยากเล่นเมต้อง
กดตรงไหนอ้าๆๆเดี๋ยวๆๆอ๋อๆมีกากบาทข้างบน
ใช่มั้ยคุอใช่ค่ะกดกากบาทมีกากบาทตรง
นี้โอเคเรมก็กดออกก็กลับไปที่เกมปุ๋ยทำ
ยังไงให้ชนะอครูพ้าเห็นตรงนี้มั้ยเนี่ย
สุขภาพกับพลังอ๋อมีสุขภาพกับพลัง
ด้วยใช่เรามีเหรียญอยู่ 150 เหรียญ
นะเราทำยังไงดีล่ะเราต้องเพิ่มมยอันนี้
คือเา้าให้เราเพิ่มใช่มั้ยคะถ้าเราเลือก 1
สุขภาพแปลว่าตรงนี้เราก็จะเพิ่มขึ้นมย
อันเนี้ย
พลังของเราก็จะเพิ่มขึ้นนะคะเพิ่มขึ้นยม
ก็ไม่รู้นะเออแต่ถ้าเราเลือกพาวหรือว่า
เลือกพละความแข็งแรงความแข็งแรงนะคะความ
แข็งแรงเราอาจจะตบแรงขึ้นอืใช่ตบแรงขึ้น
หรือเปล่าเราจะเลือกสงสัยอยู่ว่าเสื้อตัว
นี้คืออะไร
เนี่ยคือ
อะไรเสื้ออะไรอ่ะหรือว่าเราใส่เสื้อ
เปลี่ยนเสื้อได้คุเพราะว่าเป็นแฟชั่นมาก
กว่านะคะน่าจะเปลี่ยนแฟชั่นได้อเราลืมลอง
กดดูนะได้ค่ะอ๋อเปลี่ยนเสื้อได้อืแต่ว่า
เลเวลต้องสูงใช่ต้องเลเวลอ๋อเลเวลที่ 4
อืขึ้นไปก็จะเปลี่ยนได้อ๋อโอเคตอนนี้
เปลี่ยนไม่ได้อืโอเคเอาไงดีคะครูฟ้าเรา
ต้องแบบเพิ่มสุขภาพเพิ่มพลังมั้ยเออครู
ฟ้าว่าเราเพิ่มสุขภาพก่อนมยครูเรียมลองดู
นะคะโอเคเดี๋ยวเรียมลองกดเพิ่มสุขภาพตรง
นี้ออือ่ะกดแล้วนะตได้เลยอุ๊ยจริงด้วยออ
เห็นตนี้เปลี่ยนพลังชีวิตของเราเพิ่มขึ้น
นะคะพลัง
ชีวิตบวกบวเพิ่มขึ้นอืใชแต่ว่าเหรียญตรง
นี้ก็ลดลงใช่ซื้อไงเราซื้อแล้วอ่าเหลือ
แค่ 100 เหรียญอือ้านักเรียนเติมเหรียญ
เข้ามาให้คุณครูเล่นเกมเติมเหรียญให้ครู
เล่นเกมได้หรอได้หรอครูาไม่ได้เดี๋ยวูเม
ต้องลองกดให้ได้สีเขียวดูนะคะอืเราก็ลอง
ดูกันว่าครั้งนี้เราจะชนะหรือว่าเราจะแพ้
โอเคค่ะพร้อมค่ะสีเขียวเท่านั้นค่ะพ้อม
ได้ค่ะอุยเก่งมากเก่งมากเกมาเก่งมากกู
เหลี่มตบเข้าไปเลยตบหมุนเลยอันนี้คือ
แบบ
อืเบามาก
โหเรายังอ 96 เรายังเหลือมากกว่าอยู่เนาะ
96 เนี่ยโอเคเดี๋ยวริมจะตั้งใจเอาสี
เขียวได้ค่ะครู
เรียมโตบแบบตบแบบหงายหลังอ่ะหงายหลังก็
คือหงายหลังเมื่อกี้เนาะใช่เรายังมากกว่า
เค้าอยู่นะคะเรายังมากกว่าเอยู่มากกว่า
อยู่แค่เท่าไหร่อ่ะ 4
4  4 เรียมต้องตั้งใจกดสีเขียวหูสีเขียว
ออหออหไงอ่ะตบผมคืนมา
[เพลง]
เลยตบเบามากอืตบเบามากเลยนะ
คะ
อไปไหนแล้วอ่ะูฟ้าหายไปเลยเราชนะใช่มยที
นี้เราชนะเย้ครั้งนี้เราชนะค่ะครูเรียม
เก่งมากเก่งมากสปอนเซอร์เดี๋ยวเมื่อกี้
เราตบแล้วผู้ที่เค้าเรียกว่าอะไรนะผู้
แข่งขันเหรออืๆผู้แข่งขันของเราก็กระเด็น
ตกเวทีไปเลยนะหายไปเลยหายเพราะว่าอันนี้
มันเป็นเรากำลังแบบเล่นอยู่บนเวทีเนาะอื
ใช่แล้วก็มีคนดูอยู่ข้างล่างเวที
ใช่แล้วออนั่นแหละอ่ะอันนี้มีโฆษณามาอีก
ละียมต้องลบใช่่มยอ๋อใช่กากบาทคุณเลยต้อง
กดกากบาทกากบาทกากบาทก็คือ X ใช่มยโอเค
เป็นกบาอุ๊ยเปลี่ยนคนใช่ครูฟ้าคิดว่าคน
นี้เราสู้ได้มั้ยไม่ได้ค่ะเพราะว่าพลัง
ชีวิตของเรามี
125 แต่พลังชีวิตของผู้ชายคนนี้มี
เยทำยังไงดีคะเนี่ยกูเมน่าจะต้องเพิ่ม
สุขภาพหรือเพิ่มพลังความแข็งแรงนะคะความ
แข็งแรงครั้งนี้เราลองเพิ่มพลังมยุเรียม
ใช่ๆเยเรียมกดลองเพิ่มพลังนะต้องใช้ 50
เหรียญเนาะใช้ 50 นะ 50 โอเคอ่ะกดไปเพิ่ม
เพิ่มพลังอ๋อตรงนี้ก็จะเปลี่ยนตรง
ไหนตรงที่เป็นตัวเลขข้างบน 44 ใช่ตอนแรก
35 ใช่มั้ยเลก 35 ค่ะอันนี้เปลี่ยนเป็น
44 อ๋อพลังมากขึ้นโอพลังมากขึ้นแล้วคคุณ
โอเคเดมต้องลองตบดูได้ค่ะสีเขียวเท่านั้น
นะ
โอโหตบ
หมุนตีลังคาตบ
อ๋อโอหุยครูป้าไม่ได้แล้วครูเรียมเราแพ้
แน่ๆเลยเราต้องทำอย่างอะไรสักอย่างเรา
ต้องทำอะไรสทำยังไงดีนะคะเราต้องเพิ่มอุย
เพิ่มไม่ได้เราต้องเล่นให้จบครูเรียมเล่น
ให้จบก่อนใช่ๆ
โอ๊ยอ่ะสีเขียวแบบเท้าเราแล้วอ่ะมาท้า
เรา 71 ดูนะตบเรียมตายมั้ย
เนี่ย
โหโหเราเหลือ 45 แล้วค่ะครูเรียม 45 ครู
ฟ้าแบบกดดันเรียมมากเลยอ่ะเรียมรู้สึกกด
ดันมากออครูเรียมสู้ๆค่ะสู้ๆต้องกดสี
เขียวเข้มเท่านั้นใช่อมาย God  43 โอ
ใกล้ตายมั้ยเนี่ยจะตายมั้ยอือไม่ไม่หู
ข้างนี้รู้เลยเราอ่ะชนะได้แต่จริงเหรอ
ต้องแบบกดให้ได้แบบแรงๆอ่ะอืเราต้องเรา
ต้องเราต้องทำได้ค่ะคเ้ยอ 44 ตายแน่โอ
ตโอสุดยอดูฟ้าเราเล่นเกมตั้งแต่กี่โมง
แล้วเนี่ยเราเล่นเกมออหมดเวลาแล้วเนี่ย
หมดเวลาพอดีเลยนะคะหมดเวลา
เลยไงคะทุกคนคุณครูน่ากลัวมั้ยคะคุณครู
เล่นเกมอะไรเนี่ย slap  King  slap  King
ค่ะโหแต่ว่าเราก็ชนะนะเราเล่นมาถึงเลเวล
ที่เท่าไหร่เลเวลที่ 3  3 ใช่เราชนะ
ประมาณ 2 ครั้งอ่ะแพ้ครั้งนึงโอเคก็โอเค
ก็โอเคเรา 2 คนก็ตบเก่งนะครูฟ้าตบเก่งตบ
เก่งลคิใช่ๆอ้าวนั่นไม่ง่วงแล้วอ่ะคุ
เรียมไม่ง่วงแล้วหรอ
เออไม่ง่วงเพราะว่าเล่นเกมไงคะเล่นเกม
แล้วก็หายง่วงเลยใช่มั้ยใชเออแล้วเวลานัก
เรียนง่วงล่ะทำยังไงอืนักเรียนมีวิธีมั้ย
นเรบอกว่านอนไงก็
นอนวิธีแก้ง่วงก็คือการนอนนั่นเองนะคะใช่
หรือว่าอาจจะดื่มกาแฟอืมก็แล้วแต่เนาะ
แล้วแต่แต่ว่าขอบคุณคุณครูเรียมมากเลยที่
มีเกมมาให้ครูฟ้ากับนักเรียนเล่นนะคะ
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าจะไปโหลดใส่ iPad ไว้นะคะ
โหลดใส่ iPad ไว้แล้วก็
เล่นเกมครูฟ้าบอกว่าจะแบบตบๆๆอืมพจะต้อง
เป็นนักตบที่ดี slap  King ครูพ้าเป็น
slap
King  slap  King แต่ว่าตอนนี้หมดเวลา
แล้วเนาะเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วีีดีโอหน้า
นะคะนักเรียนใช่ค่ะวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อน
แล้วค่ะครูฟ้าได้ค่ะครูเียมก็บ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ